so the political situation we have going
on this this pathetic really pathetic
group of candidates pretty much on all
fronts yeah in my opinion with Bernie
being the one exception I agree what do
you think he would make it he did he he
he obviously was socially liberal but
yeah he didn't identify as a Democrat
did he he didn't vote yeah he didn't
vote it no but he was very progressive
yeah he always chose people over
property so whatever candidate chose
people over property he would lean
towards that before he died he was happy
about Hillary back in 2008 that was he
was not around for the big Obama surge
and I know he would have been thrilled
to have seen a black president I know he
would have really been thrilled about
that and I got to be in Washington in
November picking up his Mark Twain prize
when Obama flew over my husband and I
were on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial and Obama was flew over in the
helicopter to go visit George Bush in
the White House for the first time and
all I could think about is I wish my dad
was here right now yeah it would have
brought a tear to his eye absolutely it
was a very sentimental man in that way
but but yeah but and he saw it all as
as I said all the time he
really had a detachment to it he didn't
vote he hadn't voted since McGovern lost
in 72 I think that's when his heart
really broke and yeah I struggle with
that internally that he wasn't voting
yet he was talking so much about the no
but he also felt the system is so broken
almost that it was now sure to be on
repair his logic was that you if you
vote you don't have the right to
complain if you vote let's talk about
flipping something on its head that was
like that you're part of the problem yes
completely that was his thing and he
would he'd said that a few times that I
too was like yeah but that was his
stance so and that's where he stood with
that and you know he really did he was
able to compartmentalize and detach like
I said at home rooting for Hillary happy
that you know that she was you know
shaking things up but on stage
you didn't we would never talk about you
know one way or the other I mean like
Lewis Black you know his politics you
know who he's voting for Bill Maher he
gives money he's tried to get money to
burn
money to Bernie on Fridays like I want
to give you money I can only give you
fifty four hundred dollars you're not
taking any super PAC money you know you
give a pray Bobby give him another
million dollars I mean Bill Maher
literally gave an Obama super PAC a
million dollars yeah and it was sort of
brilliant what he said because he was
like he's like I know this sounds like
I'm doing this for Obama but I'm doing
this for me because I don't want the
other guy to become frightened and
that's what he was saying Friday night -
I was like you know if you don't like
the fish eat the chicken people but do
you think as a comic there's a risk in
that because then you've shown your
cards too much and that what your dad
did and in a way by holding a little
closer I think every country has their
own approach it's it's a you know that
we're all snowflakes yeah everyone's got
their own approach to it in their own
way my dad liked being not part of it
all he liked not being having no stake
in it so that he could emotionally
detach from it I think that's how he
personally protected himself from all of
it - I personally don't think that's a
healthy way to go through life love my
dad dearly yeah I you know my dad was
like I gave up about the species IV but
gave up on the plan and and I was in my
late 30s early 40s at the time and I was
like why gee I hope to have 30 to 40
more years on the planet I'm sorry in
the species a little more and I get that
you know evolution is slow but I do
believe in the evolution of
consciousness you know so I try to do my
little part my dad he was never an
activist he was never on the frontlines
even in the Vietnam War and all that
kind of stuff mean he had opinions about
it but he's not a man who got involved
he on stage did his act you know
activism yeah and there's probably
something to be said for that that we
all in life and I'm not just talking
about comics but everybody sort of picks
very little role about how they're gonna
go about things and some people are
gonna you know have kids and try to
teach them the right thing and yes
people like your dad will have one child
but then but then teach a generation
yeah although he claimed he never
although right not about changing minds
you know you know when I used to say
please really dad like come on
oh he changed me he was professor really
mean that's what he did he you know he
had a big stick and he'd come out and
whack us all with it and go oh we don't
go oh you're right oh yeah that's
right yeah yeah that's the beauty of it
more than is that ultimately the beauty
of comedy more than anything else that
when I would watch those specials from
literally from being 12 years old to
being 35 that I would watch them and go
god this is the truth yeah and I don't
know how any other comic where I mean
even as his daughter I would feel
changed in some way by each of his shows
there was something in me some idea I
had about the world had been stretched
in a new way not always it comfortably
you know a comfortable way you know but
something had been like uh a little mind
expansion had gone on and I don't know
if there are other comics who do that I
mean I'm entertained by a lot of them
well it does it does seem that something
in comedy has changed where
counterculture doesn't seem to be very
cool anymore your dad part of the cool
this was he was counterculture and right
now if you were counterculture it really
means you're sort of against you're
against the administration so you're
somehow you're against Obama yeah I
think maybe because of all this
political correctness stuff there's a
sense that that's not cool so it's sort
of like the death of I don't know I
think there's still a lot of
Independence in that I mean I comics
have to always are always the outsider
no matter what I mean even if they vote
and they give a million dollars Bill
Maher is still gonna give Obama for
right I mean he's still got his
positions you know and Louis black too
you know he was given Bernie Bill
Maher's
yes he was ten saying I support yeah you
know and I think that really is the
independent thinking and spirit of
comedy so I think that is I really do
think that's alive and well I mean you
know I spoke about Amy Schumer earlier
when I first saw Amy Schumer three or
four years ago she was on the Roseanne
roast and I thought really dick jokes
girl like you know we fought so hard you
know and you're telling dick jokes yeah
I didn't get it I didn't get she was
playing a persona that she's kind of
pushing up against all of this stuff and
she's doing it in her
way too she's counterculture in some way
because she is taking she's really she's
she's a huge feminist and yet she's
taking some of it to task at the same
time and and I like that she makes us a
little uncomfortable around that stuff